your calculators are well they're not
just calculators their scientific
calculators now the main reason that
there are scientific calculators is
because they are built with scientific
notation in mind there's this little
button that almost no one ever uses now
is you in a limit it's just confused
can you see this guy down here you see
that one right down the bottom
what is the same times 10 and then
there's a it's up there which means some
power like say Ohio 1819 negative 5
whatever you want right so if you press
that button for instance this okay I
might say 3 3 and I'm gonna write that
times 10 you can just see yeah yeah so
because it's going little that Knicks
number if I'm about to write like I
think I had was 18 okay now unhelpfully
unhelpfully the calculator aids you back
exactly what it what you gave it what is
that why does it do that it doesn't have
enough symbology I think like minus 10
or 12 or something like that but I had
18 zeros and then I had that three other
fun too many digits for to handle
okay and this is going just on your
calculator just have a play for a second
if you multiply some big numbers okay
have a look at this right so I don't
even know what these numbers are but
these numbers are so large that if I
were to write out the answer not in
scientific notation there would not be
enough digits here so what it's done is
it's just in the background magically
convert it into scientific notation for
us does that make sense you can see
there's that number that's between 1 and
10 and then there's their x well how
many zeros do
does that make sense yeah now we'll
point out on this particular example I
mean it's a good smile I'm almost
certain no I'm absolutely sure but it's
not like it's gonna end in 15 zeroes
right it's not gonna end in 15 years how
do I know
they were disappoints right so for
example suppose my answer is this
just 5 times 10 to 15 right it's gonna
be 5 and there will be 1 2 3 4 done all
this year is there ok if I said let's go
another nesting place if I go five point
five times ten to the fifteen right I'm
still gonna have a five out the front
but you see this five see that one there
it's gonna take the place of one of the
zeros right so we're fine and then there
may be now if I had 15 significant
figures then all of these decimal places
are going to get multiplied by all of
these zeros and they'll be part of this
really nice okay so this number doesn't
necessarily mean zeros but tells you the
size the length of the number okay all
right
now if you have a look turn over a page
or two to exercise to be able to
distract you for long enough for me to
actually prancin questions up but I just
want you to put your eyes on yeah I'll
just I'll just ask you a word on page 38
yeah I don't want you to rely on this
blood shot too much really all it's
doing is helping you ask two questions
right is that number at the front
between one and ten is this number of a
here in the index notation and is it
space ten right that's all you're
looking for to make something scientific
notations and we had a look at some some
counter examples so knows that look like
scientific Tunisian but they're not
really they don't have all the features
we're after so read that once but don't
draw it or don't memorize or anything
like that you're just looking for these
main features okay